all right at some point the draft will
happen now in 2011 the draft happened
before free agency and who knows maybe
that'll happen now but when the draft
does occur on april 23 through 25 mds
and again the the nfl
the most they'll say is they're
considering alternative plans they're
not going to come out and say that
they're scrapping the current plan until
they have to but here's the bottom line
all those people who show up at the
draft right they're just part of the tv
show and the nfl has realized it seems
like a bigger deal when there are tens
of thousands of people that the camera
pans past it happened for the first time
where it really grabbed my attention in
philadelphia a few years ago and they're
thinking las vegas strip all these
people it's going to look great on tv
well if the people aren't going to be
there they need to come up with an
alternative tv show and that's what it's
ultimately about it's the ultimate
reality show about nothing they don't
need to do it on tv they don't need to
do it anyway they can do it by group
text message if they wanted to with 32
teams in the league office and the
league office says okay
the cults are on the clock you got 10
minutes and then they say who they want
they go on to the next one they don't
need to do this they'll find a way to do
it where roger goodell will be somewhere
and as he announces the names one at a
time we will hold our breaths
and tune in and the audience will be in
the millions and it's going to be easy
to do he can do it from his house right
i'm sitting in my house you're sitting
in his house i said this earlier today
they could do a fireside chat with
slippers and a pipe and a dog and a
newspaper and a crackling log and he
could read off the names as they come in
and it will do great ratings because
ultimately that's all that matters all
this other stuff is just props all that
we're tuning in for is roger goodell
reading off the names of the 32 picks in
round one that's the focal point of the
draft and that isn't going to change the
how it looks where it is that may be
different but at the end of the day it's
godel reading off the names they can do
it anywhere and it's going to generate
huge ratings mds
yeah and espn and nfl network can still
televise it they can just have people
sitting in studios they can show all the
same college highlights they can have
their analysts talk about the the
strengths and weaknesses of each player
drafted they can
have the players wherever they are if
the players are at home
they can
they can still be interviewed remotely
about
what do you think of this team that just
drafted you it
it can really all happen
without any fans
and again
i just think the nfl could have shown
leadership by saying
in advance at the start of this week
the draft isn't going to happen the way
we planned for it to happen it just
isn't safe for our society
for us to be telling football fans
across the country
fly to las vegas at the end of april and
we're having a big football party that
just isn't a responsible thing to do
right now so we're gonna give our fans
the heads up right now we're not doing
it that way if you were making travel
plans you've got time to cancel them now
and i'm surprised the nfl hasn't done it
yet
because i i just cannot imagine
a scenario
i can imagine a scenario when we're
better off
in late april than we are right now i
can't imagine a scenario when everybody
just thinks hey it's perfectly fine to
have fans of 32 nfl teams all flying to
las vegas and have 10 000 of them
congregating together in one auditorium
i i just can't imagine that we'll be
saying that in less than six weeks and
that's what it would take to hold the
draft
anthony fauci one of the most compelling
and persuasive and authoritative voices
in the federal government on this crisis
was on good morning america earlier
today and he said it may be eight weeks
minimum before we can suspend this
effort to reduce mass gatherings the nfl
needs to be pr processing that
information and acting according and
again this gets back to leadership what
a powerful message it would send mds if
roger goodell would go on tv and say
what you just said now is not the time
to be making plans for mass gatherings
and hoping that maybe it'll work out now
is the time to be proactive and say
even if
somehow some way the clouds part and the
threat lifts and we can have a hundred
thousand people in las vegas now isn't
the time to do it we'll go back to las
vegas in what is it 2022 is that the
next one that's open there's a there's a
draft coming up it's like cleveland and
then two years after that kansas city
and there's one in between that's open
and it may be 2022 because that's when
the packers are trying to get go back to
vegas then but show leadership because
and this is where they are falling down
in their responsibility that that comes
with being the biggest sport
in america the responsibility to lead
the responsibility to let everyone know
that this is a serious situation to fill
the vacuum and fill the void created by
a federal government that is failing to
exercise its obligations in that regard
at the highest levels and that's the
most i'll say on that but i think that
number one
the draft isn't going to happen the way
they've envisioned it number two it's
not going to matter because as long as
roger goodell is able to read the names
off of the card 32 times on that
thursday night april 23rd it's going to
have huge ratings because that's why we
tune in we don't care whether or not the
players are there we don't care whether
or not there are 90 000 people present
yeah it makes it feel like a bigger deal
but it's still ultimately to find out
who the 32 picks are
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports